Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Polat. Ich bin hier auf dieser Station als
S.T. und würde gerne Ihnen mit einem Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie zusammen verstanden? Ja, ja, natürlich. Hauptsache, es guckt
jemand nach mir. Okay. Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden
sprechen, werde ich Ihnen Ihre persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Erstmal, wie heißen Sie das? Ich heiße Brigitte, Meister.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, B-R-I-T-I-T-E. Brigitte. Und der Familienname ist Meister.
M-E-I-S-T-E-R. Meister, genau. E oder mit R? E-R-Mäste.
Wie der Bürgermeister? Nur ohne Bürgermone.
Frau Meister, stimmt? Ja, ja. Okay, Frau Meister, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 57 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15.08.65. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter. Wie viel wegen Sie? 62 kg noch.
Okay, Frau Meister, was für Beschwerden haben Sie? Wie kann ich helfen?
Ja, ich habe solche Häftigungsschmerzen in der linken Leiste.
Also, das wird immer schlimmer. Und die Schmerzen, die strahlen auch so aus und in das ganze linke Bein.
Und das ist mir alles ein bisschen unheimlich. Wobei, ich muss dazu sagen, ich hatte vor vier Wochen eben eine Operation.
Und zwar ist mir am Bein ein Medanom entfernt worden. Und da sind auch die Lymphknoten in der Leiste entfernt worden.
Und dass es da jetzt wieder weh tut, das macht mir natürlich Angst.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich komme gleich vorbei.
Ja, diese Beschwerden steht in der linken Leiste.
Ja, genau.
Und die Strahlung in der linken Bein.
Ja.
Welche haben Sie in den Beschwerden angefangen?
Wann haben Sie die Beschwerden angefangen?
Eigentlich hat das gestern angefangen. Und da bin ich auch gleich gekommen.
Sie haben gut gemacht.
Ja, wie können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben? Sind Sie eher dumm vor der drückenden Klopfung?
Vielleicht am ehesten drückenbrennend.
Aber es kampf auch so.
Das fährt immer so rein. Es sind immer so Attacke.
Krampfartig.
Die Schmerzen gehen manchmal weg.
Ja, das sind so Wellen. Aber es wird eigentlich immer schlimmer.
Ja, verstanden.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Ja, bei Bewegung werden Sie ein bisschen...
Wenn ich mich schone, wenn ich mich gar nicht bewege, dann geht das auch.
Man kann dann nicht immer nur still sitzen.
Ja, wenn Sie die Schmerzen schmerzen würden.
Ja, dann ist es nicht ganz so unangenehm.
Aber wenn ich rumlaufe, ist es ganz unangenehm.
Und das, was mir auch aufgefallen ist, kriegt so schlecht Luft.
Das wird auch schlechter.
Wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrengen,
das, was ich hier nur der Weg bis zum Krankenhaus,
muss ich schon so pusten.
Und wenn ich dann erst mal wieder sitze, geht es besser.
Diese Luftnot beginnt mit dieser Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat zusammen angefangen.
Wenn ich ruhe, ist es besser.
Wenn ich rumlaufe, ist es schlechter.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stilfrost?
Mir ist nicht warm.
Ich habe Stilfrost, habe ich auf keinen Fall gehabt.
Und Fieber, ich fühle mich auf keinen Fall fierig.
Leiden Sie unter Kalten Schweiz?
Nein, ich nicht.
Hatte Sie einen Unfall?
Ein Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der Läste so abgenommen?
Ja, ich habe so 4 kg abgenommen.
Mit welchem Platz?
Das ist so 2 Monate.
In 2 Monaten haben Sie 4 kg abgenommen.
Ja, aber es ist sich ganz gut.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Zur Zeit ist es nicht so gut.
Aber eigentlich habe ich immer ganz gut gegessen.
Ich habe dann auch nicht Chemotherapie angefangen.
Da ist mir natürlich immer schlecht geworden.
In der Phase konnte ich dann nicht so gut essen.
Es ist auch nicht erstaunlich, dass ich abgenommen habe.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie wegen Melanom operiert wurden.
Bis wann haben Sie diese Krankheit?
Vor 4 Wochen war die OP.
Meine ich Melanom?
Ja, vor 4 Wochen ist es operiert worden.
Vor 6 Wochen hat man es festgestellt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie eine Chemotherapie bekommen haben.
Wann haben Sie bekommen?
Wir haben vor 2 Wochen angefangen.
Ich habe nicht wieder die Sachen heißen.
Ich habe einen Plan, den habe ich in der Einde nicht mitgenommen.
Was ich nehme, müssen Sie vielleicht bei meinem Hausarzt anrufen.
Welche Medikamente das sind.
Ja, ich kann Ihre Hausarzt anrufen.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit?
Ja, schlecht ist mir zurzeit.
Seit wann leiden Sie?
Ich denke, das hängt vielleicht mit der Chemo zusammen.
Seit 2 Wochen.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Wie das zum Glück nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist eigentlich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten, durchschlafen?
Ja, schlafen ist es derzeit nicht so das Wahre.
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen, weder gut einschlafen, noch durchschlafen.
Seit wann?
Das ist bestimmt schon 6-8 Wochen.
Seit ich diese Diagnose weiß, dass mich das so umtreibt.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Herzklopfen oder Herzstolpen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, vom Herzen her habe ich keine biswerden.
Frau Meister, jetzt möchte ich über Vorerkrankungen frage stellen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich bin nicht ganz gesund.
Ich nehme übeprofen 400 gegen Schmerzen.
Aber mit dem Chemo, das ich genau bekomme,
ist alles neu.
Ich kann jeden Haushalt erfahren.
Aber ich habe nicht verstanden, wie viel Milligramm für übeprofen?
400.
Nehm ich 3 mal eine.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, wie viel Milligramm für übeprofen.
400.
Nehm ich 3 mal eine.
Ist das geholfen?
Hat das geholfen?
Bei diesen Schmerzen hilft es nicht mehr so richtig.
Nichts geholfen.
Die Schmerzen in der Leiste sind trotzdem so heftig.
Und diese ausstrahlenden Schmerzen.
Das hat jetzt dafür geholfen.
Das ist für die Wunde.
Da war es schon gut, dass ich das hatte.
Ist bei Ihnen allergisch?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendein Allergisch bin.
Bisher habe ich Medikamente als Essen immer alles gut vertragen.
Gut.
Sind Sie völlig geimpft?
Gegen Corona bin ich komplett geimpft.
Ja, super.
Frau Meister, möchte ich Ihnen wieder zurück zu Ihrer Beschwerden kommen.
Sie haben die
Beschwerden in der linken Bein ausstrahlen.
Aber bis welcher Bereich?
Bis nie.
Von der Leiste in den Oberschenkel rein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die linken Bein geschwollen hat?
Ja, ich habe das.
Ich habe das.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die linken Bein geschwollen hat?
Geschwollen ist? Nein, das ist nicht geschwollen.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Auch diese Schmerzen in den Oberschenkel.
Ist die Schmerzcharakter aufdrückend?
Dumf, ja.
Ich möchte, haben Sie regelmäßige Siklus?
Ja, ich bin in den Wechseljahren.
Frau Meister, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz gelegen, ich trinke mein Glas Wein.
Wenn etwas zu feiern ist, habe ich auch kein Alkohol getrunken.
Ne.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Sie meinen irgendwie Heroin oder Cux oder so?
Nein, das habe ich noch nie probiert.
Ja, diese Frage, nur Routinefrage, deswegen musst du mich fragen.
Frau Meister, ist in Ihrer Eltern oder Familie eine chronische Erkrankung bekannt?
Ja, meine Mutter hat ein Apoplex, die ist gelähmt und sitzt im Rollstuhl.
Beide waren gelähmt?
Nein, halbseitig.
Mein Vater ist nicht alt geworden, der ist an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Wann ist er gestorben?
Sie meinen, wie alt er war?
Ja.
Er ist 70 Jahre alt geworden.
Er hatte Lungenkrebs.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ein Schwester habe ich ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist weitgehend gesund.
Frau Meister, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite bei der Stadt im Einwohner-Mail der Amt.
Deswegen ist es auch wichtig, dass ich geimpft bin, weil ich natürlich viel Kontakte habe.
Ja, stimmt.
Viele Menschen kommen hier.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich ja.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Wir wohnen alle zusammen, ja.
Super.
Herr Meister, ich habe meineseits alle Fragen gestellt.
Aber möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe Ihnen alles erzählt.
Das ist mir schlecht, dass ich diese Schmerzen habe.
Von der Vorgeschichte habe ich Ihnen erzählt.
Ich will nur wissen, was dahinter steckt und ob ich mir Sorgen machen muss.
Erstmal muss ich verstehen,
dass Ihre Beschwerden so schnell wie möglich wissen möchten.
Aber jetzt kann ich nichts genau sagen, ohne körperliche Unterlucht und ohne Diagnostik.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt körperlich untersuchen,
und danach Ultraschall durchführen auf Ihre linken Leiste.
Dann nehme ich einen Blut ab.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse bekomme, besprechen wir nochmal
und über Ihre Diagnose sprechen.
Gut.
Alles klar.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala?
11 bis 10?
Ja, die sind bei 5.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit bemerkt, dass Sie nervös und unruhig sind?
Ja, ich bin schon unruhig und nervös,
aber auch wegen der familiären Situation, wo es gerade Probleme gibt.
Das ist nicht neu.
Wenn Sie eine Chemotherapie bekommen,
und die Geschicht noch etwas zur Selben seid,
dann werden Sie eine andere Therapie hineinbluten.
Das ist operiert worden,
und diese Chemo soll eigentlich zur Sicherheit sein.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie würden Ihre Luftknoten entfernen.
Auf Ihre Beine?
Welche Beine?
Im linken Bein.
Warum haben Sie unseren Notfallambulanz gegangen?
Ich habe Hausarzt oder Onkollegier.
Der Hausarzt ist im Urlaub und das hat gestern angefangen und dann bin ich gleich heute morgens losgelaufen.
Diese Schmerzen sind plötzlich angefangen.
Wir haben gestern angefangen, ziemlich plötzlich.
Danke schön.
Habonkollegen, andere Frage.
Haben Sie Kraftlosigkeit in linken Beinen oder Krippen oder Taubheitsgefühl?
Das ist nö, ist nicht beschrieben, nein, habe ich nicht.
Frau Narlan, können wir anfangen? Arsas Geşipre?
Ja.
Gut.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Hallo.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen diese Patientin vorstellen, hätten Sie seit...
Ja, klar.
Ja.
Die 57-jährige Patientin stellte sich bei uns wegen heftiger Schmerzen
in linken Leisten mit Ausstrahlung in ganz linken Beinen vor.
Ganz oberchenkel vor.
Die Schmerzen hat seit gestern angefangen und die Schmerzen haben seit gestern angefangen
und wird immer verschlimmert.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass die Schmerzen drückend und krampfartig sind.
Ja.
Auch der Wirkung abhängig.
Auch die Patientin klagte über Düstne wegen dieser Schmerzen.
Hatte sie eine entsprechende Symptome?
Hatte sie kurze Atme oder blaue Lippen?
Ja, habe ich nicht gefragt.
Okay.
Und...
Ja, okay.
Warte.
Die Patientin hat...
Die Patientin sagte, dass diese linken Beinen keine Schwellungen,
keine Krüben oder keine Taubhauch gefühlt bemerkt.
Ja, ja.
Gefähr...
Vor vier Wochen wurden die Patienten wegen Melanom operiert.
Wo war das lokalisiert?
In linken Beinen.
Okay, ja.
Auch während der Operation wurden leftknoten infant.
Okay.
In dieser Seite.
Ja, alles vegetative, Anamnese.
Er gab Gewicht, Abnahme, 4 kg in zwei Wochen,
zwei Monate, auch Neusea, aber wegen Chemotherapie.
Und Schlafstörungen seit sechs Wochen.
Ansonsten ist unaufheilig.
An vor Erkrankungen findet sich keine...
Ja, außer der erwähnten Malignomenerkrankung.
Ja, Malignomenerkrankungen.
Die Patientin nimmt, hat vor bis zwei Wochen eine Chemotherapie
eingenommen.
Jetzt nimmt wegen dieser Schmerzen Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm ein.
Wie oft?
Einmal morgen.
Die Patientin, ja, ich habe gerade...
Sind wegen Melanom operiert worden in linken Beinen.
Und keine Allergie ist bei ihr bekannt.
Die Patientin ist gerade im Wechseljahr.
Sie ist nicht raucherin und trinkt gelegen die Alkohol.
Bei der Familienanamnese hat ihre Mutter Apoplexy.
Deswegen ist sie in Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Auf ein Rollstuhl angewiesen?
Ja.
Also hat sie Folgen von dem Apoplexy?
Apoplexy, genau.
Ihr Vater ist wegen lungankarsinom gestorben.
Die Patientin hat eine Schwester und sie ist gesund.
Die Patientin ist ein Meldarmsin.
Sie ist bei der Stadt beschäftigt.
Sie ist verjointed und eine Tochter.
Sie wohnt mit der Familie zusammen.
Nach dieser Anamnestige Angabe,
die am ersten Lymphstau.
Aber das Bein ist nicht geschwollen.
Deswegen habe ich diese Erkrankung ausgeschlossen.
Was könnte es denn noch sein?
Die Linken leisten.
Ausdreiend in den Bein.
Und sie hat das Blöde.
Ich weiss nicht, ich leuchte.
Sie hat ein Melanom als Vorerkrankung.
Das sollte man sicherlich auch noch mit ihnen betrachten.
Was kann das denn blöderweise machen?
Sie könnte Anämie haben.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Erwähnt war schon die Frage, ob sie eine Wundentzündung hat.
Was könnte es denn noch sein?
Sie hat Schmerzen in der Leiste.
Und sie hat Schmerzen im Bein.
Man weiß nicht, wie schnell das Melanom operiert wurde.
Wie lange sie das schon hatte.
Vielleicht mithaus daße.
Ja, in die Richtung ist zumindest der Fall angelegt.
Die vermuten, dass sie möglicherweise eine Filialisierung hat.
In die Knochen und in die Lunge.
Was machen Sie, wenn Sie die Patientin untersuchen?
Worauf achten Sie?
Ich muss auf die Leiste- und Wundbereich beachten.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Was könnte da sein?
Ich werde auch Puls-Tasten.
Ja, fadet nie.
Druckempfindlichkeit in der Leiste-Testen.
Also einfach palpieren, ob da irgendetwas zu tasten ist.
Ob da noch ein geschwollener Lymphknoten ist.
Palpieren.
Worauf sollte man sicherlich noch achten Pulse haben?
Für moralisch.
Und dann eben auch gucken, ob tatsächlich kein Bein-Odeem da ist.
Sie hat ja selber gesagt, da ist nix.
Vielleicht hat sie das einfach nur nicht bemerkt.
Was ist denn eine relativ simple Methode, um zu gucken, ob das Bein dicker ist?
Eine Messung.
Ja, genau.
Das gute alte Zentimeter-Maß.
Eine bestimmte Stelle gucken und schauen, ob die beide gleich dick sind.
Das sind so Sachen, die man in der körperlichen untersucht.
Wie ist das noch wegen der Disple im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich veranleise einen Röntgen, Torax.
Weil der körperlichen Untersuchung, was machen Sie denn erst mal?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, auskultieren.
Ja, sie häuschen die ab, ne?
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist eine katholische Geräusche oder Verminderung.
Genau.
Und was würden Sie jetzt apparativ relativ zügig machen?
Ja, viel Disney.
Ja, werde ich einen Röntgen, Torax.
Was könnte man denn da erst mal noch machen?
Viel Lustnord oder Kapillärfüllung?
Nee, ich meinte die Sauerstoff-Sättigung.
Ja, das ist ja eine relativ leichte Übung, mal zu gucken,
ob die bei ihrer Disple genug Luft kriegt.
Ja, ja.
Das kann man ja schnell checken.
Und was machen Sie mit der Leiste, technisch?
Unfreschal.
Jawohl.
Der Unfreschal.
Genau.
Und gucken Sie nur in die Leiste?
Oder wo gucken Sie noch hin?
Ich schaue beiseite Leiste.
Alle Fälle, beide Seiten, klar.
Und was gucken Sie noch?
Den Oberschenkel.
Und vielleicht können Sie ja auch noch pro-plizial.
Ja, aber was würden Sie noch machen?
Wenn Sie vermuten, die hat irgendwas im Rahmen
und die hat etwas im Rahmen der Leiste,
dann hat man eine gute Leisierung.
Was würde man da sicherheitshalber auch mal eben gucken?
Einmal über den Bauch mit dem Sonne.
Ja, stimmt.
Dass man guckt, ob da irgendwo was auffälliges ist,
freie Flüssigkeit oder irgendwie sowas.
Gut, Sonne ab dumm, englischalbereich,
ja.
Labo, in Labo werde ich
Blutbild, CRP,
normale Labo-Walternierung.
Ja, also Blutbild, CRP.
Wir müssten vielleicht nochmal die Trombose
ein bisschen ausschließen.
Da könnte man nochmal die Dirille bestimmen.
Ja, stimmt.
Und was haben wir denn hier noch?
Ja, das sind so die Hauptsachen, ne?
Und ja, die hier haben ja noch so als Differenzialdiagnose,
dass die möglicherweise irgendwie Probleme
mit der Niere hat.
Wenn das hier eine Leiste strahlt,
nicht so ganz auszuschließen, zumindest.
Deswegen haben die jetzt hier zusätzlich noch
einen Urinstatus empfohlen.
Ja, ich weiß, ich finde, ich lieg jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
auf der Hand, aber gucken kann man ja mal.
Okay, gut.
Ja, womit fangen Sie an mit der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, okay.
Und dann nehmen Sie die Patientin auf, oder?
Ja, ich nehme diese Patientin auf, weil Sie
Metastase haben könnten.
Ja, ja.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden,
was bei der Patientin rauskommt.
Über die Untersuchungsergebnisse.
Und dann können wir die ja auch noch zusammengesprächen.
Alles klar.
Ja, okay.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, Sie haben sprachlich
noch ein bisschen Probleme.
Ja, weil ich sehe auch nicht Schwenker.
Ja, und zwar, manchmal lassen Sie die Artikel weg.
Und mit Ausfallung in den ganzen linken Oberschenkel,
oder die Patientin ist in Wechseljahren.
Die Patientin ist in den Wechseljahren.
Ja, das sind keine schlimmen, dass man versteht,
das trotzdem, ja.
Aber es ist sprachlich noch ein bisschen unsicher,
würde ich sagen.
Aber für die erste Anamnese fand ich es eigentlich wirklich okay.
Und Sie haben sich wacker geschlagen mit dieser ja
wirklich etwas komplizierten Patientin.
Der ist ja, dass eigentlich unser Thema nicht so gut passt,
weil die ja mit ihrer vorhandenen Diagnose schon mal reinplatzt.
Ja, die kommt ja nicht als unbeschriebenes Blatt,
sondern die sagt ja schon mal, BANG, ich habe diese Beschwerden,
aber ich hatte vor vier Wochen diese Béla-Norm-Operation.
Das ist natürlich eine bisschen untypische Situation,
weil das ja eigentlich schon ein, auch in so eine Richtung,
so ein bisschen lenkt.
Und weil das ja auch schon bedingt,
dass diese Patientin vorbehandelt ist, logischerweise.
Ja, normalerweise, wenn ich Anamnese erhoben habe,
ja, konnte ich nicht Diagnose oder Verdachtdiagnose finden.
Deswegen konnte ich nicht richtige Frage direkt stellen.
Ich musste vielleicht ein bisschen denken.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das ist ein Düsseldorferfall,
Herr Genüß.
Richard Meisen.
Ja, klar.
Düsseldorferfall.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Düsseldorferfall.
Ich weiß nicht mit welcher Aktualität,
aber das ist jedenfalls eine klassische Düsseldorfer-Patientin.
Und diese Situation ist eben ein bisschen anders als bei den anderen,
weil sie mit der Diagnose schon kommt
und nur die akuten Beschwerden noch dazu hat.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt, die Anamnese-Aufnahme fand ich eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Das war wie gesagt ein bisschen unsicher in der Sprache, aber okay.
Und in der Präsentation ist es noch nicht ganz flüssig, sagen wir mal.
Aber ich was will mal beim ersten Mal erwarten,
also eine Brunnen dauernd etwas länger.
Dann haben Sie Ihre Prüfen, wissen Sie schon?
Ja, zur Wörft erneunter.
Wann?
Zur Wörft erneunter.
Oh, ja, okay.
Ja, dann werden wir noch die eine oder andere machen, würde ich mal sagen.
Zusammen mit dem?
Ach, die beiden haben zusammen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, mein